was was your relationship with x
uh did you have one prior to the rough
riders thing or did you like how how did
you come into the fold were you like
like with him before the rough riders or
like like explain your guys's history
i um well d you know you know d
the general is the one that put me on
the map
he was the one that believed in me first
before everybody and he brought me up to
the studio
and and it was like to battle dmx but i
didn't even know it was a battle because
i i never was battling at that time
right now i found out very fast though
you know i mean as soon as i got in
there
boom he was right there they didn't
quite waste any time too i was like i
got there what's up how you doing yo
drag what's up
yo turn that beat on right quick boom
and it was straight like that
and then he just started rapping which
was
and then i'm listening to his flow and
style delivery
i'm listening to all that i'm like okay
this dude is incredible right here
but at that time i was so hungry
franchisee so i still kept going back at
him back at him back
in the back and next thing you know a
whole hour went by we was just
back and forth training bars and even
though i lost that battle
like the whole time yeah i said he
probably battled for an hour i lost four
hours you know man
but he respected it like you know i mean
you know like to the max like he
he just was like you know what i think
we gonna keep this dude right here i
like this dude you found john saying it
was just something that he always said
that was just in my eyes that reminded
uh uh number you know that number
i always just reminded uh
me of him yeah yeah i think like uh
you you guys were it was it's almost
like you guys were so synonymous with
each other
you know what i mean it was like yo you
see dmx you see drag yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like the whole batman and robin thing
let me know that was set up
us our joint was actually genuine